at patchista said how do you get conan
to come down when he gets too hyper
you know you just have to hold him and
pat his back
it sona fixes your life
[Music]
at darren's demise says do you steal
baby stuff from stores
have i stolen anything
no
no i don't steal any
i don't
i don't steal anymore i can say that
confidently
last time i stole something was
it was a while ago it was a long time
ago what am i doing i no i stopped
stealing guys
i i'm not gonna steal something for my
babies i mean there was i think
hold on
i ordered something
and they sent me seven of them they were
squirt toys for the for the bath
and they sent me like seven of them
and
my husband who has much better
conscience than i do he's like you
should tell the story they sent you too
many and i was like yeah yeah i totally
will and then i just didn't
i'm gonna keep them all i guess that's
like stealing
i would say that's probably the last
thing i stole
do i say you're welcome for this
question do you still baby stuff from
stores
you shouldn't
but if they send you extra stuff like
whatever what are you gonna do not keep
it come on you're welcome at large ego
loose says what is the best way that
you've found so far that works to stop
the kid from crying
good god this thing
you just put them in there turn it on
and walk away
uh no but honestly my favorite thing in
this house is that inflatable ball that
you sit on and just bounce with the kid
they'll stop crying it's the best any
type of movement putting him in a
stroller the rocking chair
you know
going somewhere in the car ugh i just
want to i just want them to keep moving
and then they're quiet or stick a bottle
in their mouth
is it can you overfeed them yeah
obviously you can but
it keeps them from crying you're welcome
at aa lock 05 says how to hide the dark
realities of this world imminent lurking
eventuality of death from them
wow
wow
maybe mr rogers has an episode that
talks about the dark realities of the
world and the imminent lurking
eventuality of death
and then you don't have to do it
mr rogers can do it because he always
figured out a best way to do it
you know on pbs kids on the pbs kids app
they have like seven episodes or
something of like
old mr rogers episodes
and
there's one where he talks about the
cello
and he uh has yo-yo ma on and they do an
interview and it there's this moment at
the end where mr rogers looks at the
camera and he just goes let's think
about you know what what yo-yo ma said
about like feeling and playing the
instrument and then he's silent
for like
two minutes
and i'm not even joking i wept
i wept when that part happened
because like who's silent on tv anymore
he can do it so when you want to talk
about
you know the dark realities of the world
and the imminent lurking eventuality of
death
and you want to talk about that with
children
then you know see if mr rogers has an
episode of it
and let him do it you're welcome at
said how do you get conan to come down
when he gets too hyper
you know you just have to hold him and
pat his back
you have to shush him and you have to
give him his favorite toy and that's how
you do it you're welcome
next time one of you babysits conan
o'brien you know how to calm him down
when he gets too hyper
this is fun i miss doing this you're
welcome
[Music]